[拍手]
今から50年ほど前
南米山文にまだ地図の空白地帯が残ってい
た頃の話です
実はそのパンツやっている
三宅三谷地域には
よそ者の様子がない地域なのでそこに住ん
でいる先住民も全く文明とは接触してない
ということが分かって
胸が熱くなったことを覚えてい
ますでシュートな準備をして
ペルーのそのAmazonに向かいました
で飛行機
それからバストラック最後は丸首と
筏を乗り継いで最後は徒歩で
熱帯雨林に囲まれた山の頂上にある彼らの
家に向かいました
ところが
私が近づくと家の中からバッと真っ青な顔
をして先住民たちが出てきて
森に逃げ去ったんです
でも一緒に
スペイン語と間違いのこのわかる
案内人がいたので彼に
森に入ってもらって彼は説得してもらって
彼は害のない人間だから大丈夫ですよと
安心させて戻ってきてもらいましたこれが
町銀河の家族のお父さんとお母さんで一緒
に住んだのはおばあちゃんとそれから息子
2人6人それから娘2人
計11人の家族でし
たで彼らと同じ屋根の下で同じバナナ
芋トウモロコシショナル食べて
居候生活していくうちにだんだん打ち解け
てきましたそして私は名前を聞こうと思っ
たんですねで一人一人名前を何て言うのっ
て聞いたらいや名前はないんだって言うん
ですね
でついでにお前名前をつけてくれ」って
言う
んですでまあどうせ冗談で
使うことはないだろうと思って
適当にお父さんお母さんが父ちゃん
母ちゃんで動作が呪い人間はそろそろ
ゴナンは日本だったら五郎ですけれどそれ
じゃ面白くないけどゴロゴロと続けました
なんとその1歳の子にゴロゴロ助けたん
ですけども今50歳です50年付き合って
んで彼らとそれから年齢も聞いたんですね
そしたら
案内人が適当なこと言ってるようなので
数字教えてよっつったら
123はパーニルピテに舞うわって言うん
ですね4はつったら
怖いにじゃあ5はっつったら永遠になんと
彼は123しかなくてあとは全部たくさん
なんですね
結局年齢は分かりませんでした
で逆に彼らからが私に興味持ってきて聞い
てきたのは他の場所だったらあんたどこの
国から来たの中国韓国と聞いていくんです
けども彼らはどこの川から来たのって聞い
てきたんですねで私はその時の国立に住ん
でたので多摩川つったら聞いたことねえな
そうですねで興味や動物いるの
魚いるのドリルのっていくからまあ
そこそこいるよっつったらそこそこかどの
くらいかかるんだこれが証言が難しいん
ですね2週間買って行ったんですけども
東京から
2週間という表現数字が3しかないので
結局表現したのは
詩月から満月に
うつつきが変わるぐらいだよっつったら
なんだ隣の川じゃないか動物のそんなにい
ないんだったらここに家族で住みに来れば
いいんじゃないかと言われてしまいました
で彼らは頭の中に入れる地図が
森とカートだけでできてからどこの川から
来たんだって聞いたわけですね
別に世界中は教育が
進んで私たちは全部全世界が同じ地図を
持っちゃっていますでも彼らは海
砂漠を見たことないんじゃなくて知らない
んですねですから彼の頭の中にある地図は
森とかだけでできているんです
で彼らに止めてもらいながら彼らの暮らし
を見ていると私たちと違いが見えてきまし
た
それは何かというと家に入って
柱とか屋根とかひょうたんとか
敷物とか見てみると全部
素材のわからないものないんです皆さんの
中で持ち物で
素材を自分で自然から取ってきて作った
もの持ってる人いますか
彼らはそういう生活してるんですだから
人材のわからないものないんですね
要するに私たちはいかに自然から離れて
しまって彼が自然の中で暮らしている
ところがわかると思いますさらに印象的
だったの彼らのゴミ
排泄物したいです
例えばゴミ彼ら
とか
瓢箪とか
芋の皮とか綺麗に掃除して森に捨てに行き
ますそうすると動物が食べ虫が食べ最後は
微生物が分解して水に戻ります
排泄物は野糞しますこれも自然に戻ってき
ますじゃあ死体はどうするか
川に水槽かどうそうです土葬にするとつい
戻ります代わりの流すと
魚が食べてくれてそれがやっぱり取材主体
になってやっぱり自然に戻ってくるん
です彼らは
全く自然と同じ
循環の輪の中にいるんですねそれに対して
私たちはどうでしょうか
私たちの
ゴミ全部
燃やしてしまいます
じゃあ
排泄物はどうか
推薦免除で
排泄物を流すと
結局最後は固形化して
燃やして二酸化炭素にしちゃいます死体は
どうか
火葬にしてしまいますゴミも死体も
排泄も全部自作炭素にして全く役に立た
ないんですね
少し話を変わりますが皆さんビッグ
ファイブで聞いたことありますか地球は
46億年前に生まれました
そして38年8億年前に生命が生まれまし
た
その間に5つの大きな絶滅器があったん
ですね私たち今3000万種の生命がいる
と言われていますがその生き物全部がその
絶滅期を奇跡的に乗り越えてきた生き物
なん
ですじゃあその最後の
絶滅危機が調理後滅んだ6600万年前
ですその時私たちの先祖はどんな姿をして
たかというと
ジネズミ委託小さくて夜行性で
虫を食べているような生き物でしたそれが
恐竜滅んだと森の中に入るサルが生まれ
そして
類人猿になり最後に森を出て人間が生まれ
ました
じゃあ今は何が起こってんでしょうか
実はビックスヒックス真っ只中なんです
ビックスヒックって分かりますか
動物がいっぱい滅んです生き物が滅んで
いきますそれがアフリカゾウインドウ像
オランウータン
ゴリラチンパンジー北極熊
全部強くて大きな動物が主に絶望して絶滅してるんですね
ビッグ5の時はまだ人間がいませんでした
だから
原因は
天変地異でしたところが
ビッグ6
は
人間の仕業です
森林の伐採開発
住処の汚染
それから取りすぎ
あるいは
密漁
外来種の移設
そして
気候変動
すべて私たちが自然に行っている悪さのせいなんですね
これはオランタンです
ボリュームのネットをマレーシアの森の中ですが彼らの絶滅に瀕しています
なぜか
これがヤシ油を作るアブラヤシです
これはボルネオ島がどんどんどんどん
これが侵食していっています
これ見てください
向こう側が原生林です
こちらが
ヤシ油がどんどんどんどん
押し寄せてきて
そして彼らの生息域がなくなってきてるん
これはそこに住んでるペグミアジアゼル
ですけども裏蓋と同じように絶滅に瀕して
います近々
害虫展というのが行われます
これは何かというと
害虫をモチーフにしてアート作品を募集し
てその融資促進を展示する展覧会ですその
審査員で生物学の縦の3と対談をしてくれ
と被災したと言われた対談しましたその時
の共通認識は
害虫とか外注って何だろうねこれは人間
中心に考えた考え方なったということで
一致しました例えばハエその子供の幼虫の
氏を考えてみると私たちにとっては
害虫です
病気の原因になったりうんこを食べたり
意味嫌われてる生き物ですねでも彼らは
自然界では例えば花を咲かす生き物にとっ
ては彼らが自分を助けてくれますあるいは
氏は
脊椎動物や無脊椎動物を
主体を食べて自然に土に返してくれるん
ですね実は自然界の中ではハエもウジ虫も
益虫なんです
自然界では必要ない生き物なんかいないん
ですね
ではこの地球上の最悪の
害獣って何でしょう
明らか人間ですよねでアメリカの生物学者
レイチェルカーソンは沈黙の春の中で
地球は人間のためにだけあるのではないと
言っています愛のとか北米南米の先住民の
民話とか神話の中にはそんな地球中心に
人権中心的でない考え方が散りばめてい
ます
あるいは私はチベット文化圏に長くいて
いるんですけども彼らは
祈りに満ちています何で祈るのかって聞い
てみたですそしたら一つはより良き
ライセンスに行くため
もう一つは実は
生きとし生けるものが全てが幸福になる
ようにというのと言っています
実は
欧米から見れば遅れた地域にそういう
ヨーロッパ中心主義でない考え方が
古くから根付いているんですね
人間は自然の循環の輪から外れてしまい
もう野生に戻ることはできません
で私たちは人間自然がないと生きていけ
ないでも自然あるいは野生動物は人間は
必要ないん
です場合によっては
邪魔者ですその上
地球の一番の害獣は
人間だって言うと
ある人はそれじゃ人間なんか滅んじゃった
でもいいのですねって言ってきます私は
そう思いません
人間はそういう確かに
人間は地球上の最悪の害獣だってことに
気づいてそして
反省してじゃあどうしていいかってことを
考えるのが人間です実は猿は木から落ちて
大怪我してもどうするか実はその大怪我し
た足を受け入れてそのまま生きてきます
でも人間はどうか
木から落ちて大怪我すると後悔します
そして
反省してじゃあこれからどうすれば
怪我をしないかということを考えます
Amazonに400ぐらい民族がいるん
ですけども一つの民族だけ
過去未来がない民族がいますピザハンと
いう民族ですけども彼ら文法上
過去も未来もないんですねですから戦争
崇拝もないしお墓もありません
彼は幸せです
過去がないから後悔しないんです
未来がないから不安がないでも私たちは
そうはいきませんじゃあどうすればいいん
だろうかと考えた場合に私たちは自然から
の
循環の輪から外れてしまってまあ他の
生き物たちに迷惑かけてるわけですねで
やっぱり今の
まあ自然
人間中心主義の行動パターンから
考え直さなきゃいけないと思います
もちろんあまり人間逆に
極端な自然中心主義の考え方は論外ですね
でも他の生き物たちのことを考えるそう
いう考え彼らの
に対しての想像力あるいは共感力を大切に
していきたいと思います
実はもう一つ何とかしなければいけないの
が私たちの欲望です
欲望はもちろん私たちが生きていくために
必要なものですだけども問題なのはあまり
にも煽られて
膨らんできた
膝下欲望です要するにそれが生産至上主義
消費至上主義を見今の私たちの地球の生態
系を蝕んで他の生き物たちの
命を蝕んでいるのです
人間が地球最後の最悪の害獣であることを
気づいて自然界の循環の輪から外れて地球
に迷惑を
かけてばかりいることに気づいたならば
底なしの貪欲さを抑えて
欲望をほどほどにして
弟にすればよりサステナブルで指揮官な
生き方をに近づくことができると思ってい
ます
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]